When it comes to Dan Harmon and Justin Roiland's
weird and witty adult-centric animated series
Rick and Morty, you'd be forgiven for thinking
that just about anything goes.
An entire storyline parodying Freddy Krueger
and the Nightmare on Elm Street franchise?
Yep, that happened.
A character made from the DNA from Abraham
Lincoln and Adolf Hitler?
Yeah, that too.
Whole episodes made up entirely of vignettes
from television series that only air in other
dimensions?
You betcha.
"God-damn!"
Basically, fans of Rick and Morty are no strangers
to the bizarre.
So it'd be easy to believe that practically
every idea the creative team pitches gets
accepted, no matter how bonkers it may be.
But that isn't the truth.
As it turns out, there was one idea the show's
creators had that never came to fruition — the
details of which remain a closely-guarded
secret to this day.
"God-damn…"
Harmon and Roiland, who introduced Rick and
Morty to the world back in December 2013,
recently revealed to Entertainment Weekly
that they abandoned one episode of the show's
upcoming fourth season while it was still
in the planning phase.
According to Harmon, the episode would have
needed a lot of elbow grease to be suitable
for mass consumption, and fixing its problems
would have taken far too long to be worth
doing.
Harmon explained:
"Justin is going to kick me under the desk
here, but I've been pushing to show at Comic-Con
an animatic for an episode that we aborted
in the early stages.
We could fix it, but fixing it would take
as long as doing a new episode."
Though neither Harmon nor Roiland offered
explicit details about the episode that never
was, Harmon noted that fans would flip over
the footage they have tucked away over at
Adult Swim — but probably wouldn't actually
like the episode if it was ever completed
and included on a season of the show.
Harmon said:
"Fans would love to watch that.
They wouldn't love it as much as [an episode]
from season 4, but second to that.
[...] And I anticipate that when presented
in that context fans would say, 'I love that,
why don't you make that?'
But I would say that if we broadcast it that
you would think it sucked."
Roiland then joked that he and Harmon would
crowdsource funding for fans to fix the rejected
Rick and Morty episode, because, as Harmon
said, if the animatic is out there, people
will find a way to animate it in full.
It's hard to say what the scrapped episode
could have been about — especially since
the show's writers seems to be given permission
to take the show in pretty much any direction,
and nothing is considered totally off-limits.
Roiland explained:
"We don't have any rules like that that I
can think of.
One philosophy we tend to adopt is to keep
moving forward with new ideas, new worlds,
and not look back as often as other shows
might, just in fear of that coming off as
disingenuous fan service.
But there's nothing 'banned.'"
Whether this missing Rick and Morty episode
will ever be unveiled remains a mystery.
But Rick and Morty fans are endlessly passionate
— after all, these are the same people who
managed to help push McDonald's into bringing
back its limited-time-only Szechuan Sauce
after it was mentioned in the series.
"I want that Mulan sauce Morty.  That's my series arch, I want my McNuggets Szechuan Sauce, Morty."
With that in mind, there should be little
doubt that they'd also figure out a way to
get the unmade episode animated and released.
Until that miracle happens, however, those
same fans will have to pass the time wondering
what that rejected episode could have been
about — and looking forward to the show's
fourth season, which premieres in November
2019.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.